official playstation 5 console covers
have been announced halo infinite is
getting some new playlists and more
sony has officially announced a new
series of ps5 console covers priced at
55
which will come in nova pink starlight
blue and galactic purple color schemes
sony says that these galaxy inspired
colors will launch globally starting in
january 2022 at participating retailers
and can easily be applied to existing
ps5 consoles and its disk free digital
edition
simply pop the current white cover off
click the new one of your choice into
place and you'll be good to go in
addition to that new color variants of
the dual synth controller are also on
the way joining the previously released
midnight black and cosmic red versions
similar to the ps5 colors these
controllers will also be available in
nova pink starlight blue and galactic
purple back in november a patent filed
by sony implied that replacement face
plates were on the way as the company
registered documents for an ornamental
design for a cover for an electronic
device with diagrams of ps5 faceplates
being used for illustrative purposes
previously the only way to customize the
ps5 was to grab a can of spray paint or
a third-party option from companies such
as dbrand which offered dark plates for
50
that product attracted sony's legal team
in 2020 and dbrand received a fresh
legal threat from sony's lawyers which
resulted in the company shutting down
all dark plate production and replacing
them with the more distinctive dark
plate 2.0 shelves if you're looking to
grab one of the official ps5 faceplates
pre-orders are now live on sony's
website
if you're like most people when you
start up halo infinite multiplayer and
hit the quick play button you're hoping
for one thing slayer mode thus far all 4
on 4 modes have been lumped together but
that's about to change with tomorrow's
playlist update at long last you don't
have to play oddball four times in a row
as shared on reddit and twitter 343
industries adjusted its update plans in
response to players feedback instead of
waiting to release a larger slayer
focused update after the holidays the
team will have a basic slayer playlist
ready for tomorrow december 14th you'll
be able to choose from standard player
free for all fiesta slayer and tactical
slayer only two of those were in the
game already and of those two only
standard slayer has remained as a
permanent part of the quick play
rotation
the update doesn't stop there however it
will also remove some of the most
specific challenges to make the battle
pass less frustrating as well as adjust
the requirements for other challenges
including the weekly challenge which is
the most annoying one to finish so far
there will also be new challenges for
added playlists as well as a challenge
category based on accumulated player
score the 343 says is a small initial
step toward xp based on overall
performance
power on a new documentary series
detailing the storied history of the
xbox is now out on youtube to stream for
free of particular interest is the
appearance of don matrick the infamous
leader of xbox during the launch of the
xbox one in the final episode matric
left microsoft in 2013 months before the
xbox one launch signaling a big change
in the focus for xbox in the years to
come this is matrix first interview
since providing new insight into the
entire saga we got pushback from
consumers from journalists questioning
if we made the right choice as a company
explain magic it was a valid criticism
but it was a very binary choice and we
chose to bet on online as you might know
that bet didn't pay off at the time even
if that's how games are predominantly
consumed now and it led to a difficult
time for microsoft as it fought for the
future of xbox matrix left microsoft in
july of 2013 months before the xbox one
was due to launch phil spencer would
only take his position as head of xbox
almost a year later in march of 2014.
it's not all bad business decisions and
redemptive stories either the series
also dives into the mini highs of the
brand from the incredible launch of the
xbox 360 and its years of dominance over
sony's playstation 3. there's also a
breakdown of what went wrong with the
initial pitch for the xbox and bill
gates's well-known initial rejection of
the idea as well as the fight microsoft
had on its hands with the xbox 360's
infamous red ring of death debacle
which xbox console is your favorite and
why let me know in the comments below
and be sure to leave a like and
subscribe so you don't miss any future
episodes of gamespot news
[Music]
[Music]
you